I like your smile wow so you think I'm
ugly stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop stop we're good we're
good we're good I'm Bangkok Bangkok I
can't stop my turn around hit the same
spot
[Music]
hi my name is rafar how you going I'm
good how are you I'm good I'm good yep
thank you
so you try to make chocolate vanilla as
well
no I'm Teo um hang on tail um I don't
have a pickup line that I kind of do
pick you up and we can do lines
[Music]
that is the white [ __ ]
just went up to him like you want to be
cocaine that's how she just did that
yeah pretty much hi I'm Kira hey young
Kiara I'm good how are you I'm good yeah
new experience for you uh not me this
set
nuts
ha
have you experience here not me
so yeah
look at the walkthrough she's proud of
what she did she lose [ __ ] listen lady
you could have walked up there and just
stared at him it would have had the same
result and she probably would have been
better hi I'm Jessica how you going
Jessica I'm good how are you I'm good
I'm good what was your name I'm Patrick
Patrick nice to meet you nice to meet
you
uh I have no pickup line either to be
honest
were you guys not aware of what the [ __ ]
the show was today am I me okay in their
defense maybe they weren't told they had
to come up with something you got to be
better than that okay that's enough
how you going Ash a little bit hungover
do you want to come to a rave with me
later a bit hungover yeah am I uh
am I not worthy of uh you've just been
why would I try for a guy I don't even
know if I'm into okay let's let's
explain to you what what the situation
is
you're the one that gets to try
that was the only thing
this is the type of person to go to a
job application be like no no you'd be
lucky to have me on your team now hire
me would you have any questions yeah why
should I work here
hi I'm Samara how you going tomorrow I'm
good how are you I'm good I'm good I
just did not come prepared but
um
but
but I'm such a good dancer and I'm so
good at yoga and I'm ah
back Secret she went right up to that
mic it went oh
[Music]
my otherwise have come fall together
please love me
that's that cringe nerd girl
please bring love to me whoa whoa
she did
she did I'm such a good deal
oh my God
who got that they do not know get this
jailbait ass out of here also good at
cooking yoga yeah yes please yay
hi Maria how you going Maria good what's
your name I'm Patrick good Patrick you
have really nice build thank you I uh
I'll try my best try this and where
you're from I'm from the West pick up
line not you're not supposed to start
dating now you know what it is for me
means the entitlement yes that's what
this is yeah it's like even when it's
your job to try you're still expecting
him to try the premise of the show the
premise of this is you guys are
competing for him yep I'm from marry me
because bestie yeah
bro I don't swipe around this girl
because we're in Australia just because
the way she was chewing that gum into
the mic bro the technicians should have
been like not always you gotta go
because we don't told you to take the
so where you from
yeah what do you do you got a nice build
you want to eat my [ __ ] later yeah hi
Patrick I'm Jess how you doing Jess are
you my appendix because I don't know
what the [ __ ] you do but I'm trying to
take you out
I mean I know the appendix actually does
something so I'm going to say no oh [ __ ]
I was like I mean
don't fight you attractive so I'm going
to say
he was finding a reason because it
wasn't the worst line it was better than
some of the other girls he left hi how
you going what's your name I'm Patrick
Patrick nice my name is Davina she got
that I gotta pop an Instagram starter
pack bro she got the titties out the
lips all done up the surgery going on
and the jacket around like she was
posing for like it's crazy don't forget
the lashes
you've got the baby here too
yes what's your first impression
first impression yeah
[Music]
here's my pickup line I mean if you
think about it it makes sense because I
mean ladies just know like dudes choose
with their eyes so like why am I gonna
try to have game girl choose with the
eyes too
is it that they don't have to get they
don't have to go get they're not
go-getters they're not the ones that go
go fetch they choose what they ask when
a girl says no she chose with her eyes
when a guy come up and she's like ew she
chose with her eyes she said no here's
the difference go ahead for a girl you
can't really change a dude's mind
um a guy known as with game with the
right kind of laugh the right kind of
words the right kind of whatever you can
change your mind you can go from but
maybe to a yes you would go from a note
to yes yeah
I mean you know we saying like they
don't got game but at the same time it's
like their whole life will probably talk
to them you just look good and like a
guy either say yes or no look some of
the women had no pickup lines he said no
yeah but exactly
go get it hold up and some of the women
did have pickle lives and he still said
no why because he'd already chosen once
he looked at him
he said hey man you look and tight in
that yoga pain let's go go away yeah
yeah
right he was down for it oh no so no you
no I'm not I actually the more I think
about it the more I'm not even mad at
these ladies because like that's just
Society you know what I'm saying yeah
the choose another five
eight down to five
right to left or left to right you said
eyes on that yeah the oh girl got crazy
please type of girl like he's choosing
me yeah you [ __ ] you wake up in the
middle light she's still staring at you
like this yeah you never wake up and you
could barely see in the dark but you can
make out her eyes and teeth you you [ __ ]
you for one night and then after that
the next day morning you wake up and
she's shopping for wedding dresses she
got them crazy eyes yes she comes she
comes saying I love you she's the reason
why they made the movie smile
look
up
she's terrified of the light bro look
so this young lady is a very special
person in my life she's around my place
maybe three to four times a week we get
up to a lot of Mischief playing around
all kinds of goofy things at first she
was terrified you could see uh she was
scared of the light she didn't
understand what was going on but she got
to know it a little bit and get used to
it
oh oh my goodness
[Music]
cheesy what do you think
there you go she's realizing it's fine
the Galaxy projector will light up your
room and make you think that you're in
outer space with countless stars that
nebulize surrounding you you want me to
close the light
of course so we close this boom
oh
CeCe come take your power
when I'm working when I'm home I spend
so much time editing it's nice to be
able to just switch up the lights and
feel completely different just based off
of one click of the button even using
the well integrated app where you can
change the lights based off whatever
mood you're going through so whether
you're getting romantic whether you're
having fun whether you just want to get
pensive and start thinking a little bit
differently the Galaxy projector is a
great way for you to change your route
without having to change it too much you
feel me so for those who are looking for
the perfect gift for others or
themselves this is your chance go to the
link in the description below use the
discount code Abba preach and get 20 off
so take advantage don't waste any time
click the link in the description below
yes
yes no
why the black girl look surprised like
really Now ladies you guys have to
either do one of three things
write a poem
write a wrap
or sing Patrick
yeah why is the guy behind the camera
sound like he's making it up as he goes
I'm so hungover was that thing there
where people clap like this I write a
poem yeah yeah yeah yeah we got a black
lady here uh there's an option to rap
rap by the way just the case
um one by one tell me what you're doing
yeah I'm singing a song for Patrick
honestly the whole time I just drew a
picture
get her get her out get her out get her
the [ __ ] out this is the kind of girl
that passes her class by being friends
with a teacher there's the kind of girl
that wants to please you and sticks a
finger in your butt without asking
that's what's happening right here but
nobody asked but you still did it and
now we got doo doo brown on the screen
let's go do it around
so if Patrick wants a poem I'll do a
poem If you want a song I'll do a song
If you want to rap I'll do a rap
not gonna lie that [ __ ] may be hard
okay
hey my [ __ ] is Queen you know what I'm
saying
like let's go
I'm in I'm in
I still think second farts was better
whatever
yo there's women out there who'll do it
anything man
soldiers yes
yes saying it is around you say baby I
love you if you ain't running games in
my name say my name these [ __ ] are
not for you
staple it if you sitting here if you
fitting next to me you catching a bullet
hey
these [ __ ] can't afford you okay okay
Patrick out here feel like a high value
man I'm the one that knows you better
say my name
oh
someone now you sing my name when
cameras are not rolling my heart you
were stolen baby sing my name
now the real question is
how many of these [ __ ] gonna clap
[Applause]
Instagram girl said I'm not clapping uh
this is going to be on one of my stories
later on because we're gonna have a
conversation about this is it acceptable
for a black woman to call me a [ __ ] on
the show like this this is not just
perpetuating instant misogyny
guys buy my new skincare product yeah
how do I follow
[Applause]
you said you wanted a new experience so
pick me and I'll help you feel it mine's
a little bit more lovey-dovey so cupid
hit me with position I wondered if you
look both ways when you crossed my mind
I'm sick I'm sick I'm sick of chasing
you're the one that's always running
through my Daydream I can only see your
face when I close my eyes
can I get a kiss and Let's Make It Last
Forever
she sound crazy
yo well she did that like I'm sick I'm
sick I'm sick I'm sick I'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired as I'm
tired sleepless nights I gave this
relationship all of my might as I slept
through the guise of your feelings I
felt the feeling of having felt a strong
sign a strong time a strong line of
connection between the two of us now can
you feel how sick and thick and sick and
sick I am kiss me Patrick or I'll kill
your whole family
[Laughter]
I'm gonna follow that
okay so 10 line big Curves in the energy
glows I mean I just wrote this so I hope
it flows okay rap poem or song
oh I don't know what is the what does
the board say if it says a cat then
because
you're that [ __ ]
what do you feel I was a wrap do a wrap
okay
um
[ __ ] okay [ __ ] I should have written
something
um okay
okay
um okay yeah it would have been
hilarious if she just played right into
the whole bar
and then she was fire it's like I don't
know what I would do I Bangkok Bangkok I
can't stop my turn around hit the same
spot I thank God I'm the Thriller in
Manila slog in Hong Kong call me Patrick
don't McDonald it's like a little remix
too yeah I would have just stolen lines
I I would have plagiarized like Shia
LaBeouf I don't care sitting here on the
white floor looking at you when I'm
looking at the door but wait no let me
start again wait get the [ __ ] out of
here take this stink Pig Tinker out it
was a [ __ ] done Hey listen listen Hey
listen it's not her fault that her knees
weak or arm spaghetti just two
all right just two yes
and
yes
hi how you going Grace was it no
wow that's really embarrassing good
start no name
just so I don't forget this time say it
three times okay yeah Divina
foreign
[Music]
exactly what you're saying and you're
100 right but if you put yourself in her
position she's been chosen I did all
that [ __ ] and you don't remember my name
you understand what I'm saying you are
100 right but from her perspective she
got chosen and on top of that yeah that
means my [ __ ] was good that means my
[ __ ] was amazing that means you like
that and you don't make
it's like [ __ ] play sports at a
state level think they're the best in
the world then they go out of state get
smashed at an interstate competition
it's like bro you're not special humble
yourself you're a big fish in a small
pond you're not that special if I go on
a competition and I get chosen I'm not
gonna get big-headed why because I don't
see what top dogs are like it's like
it's cool it's not that deep yeah you
get what I'm trying to say so even
though what you're saying is correct I
can still laugh at her stupid
perspective I understand that you know
that's what it comes out it's like
you're not special Davina that's one
again Davina one more time perfect Grace
Davina
how you going someone play with me
I just I'm fun like that you're fun yeah
I'll call you Grace one more time what's
your about a girl
my even about girl
um
[Music]
honesty I'm just not being honest I
don't know if that's that's bare minimum
that isn't it one last question what was
the first thing you always about me
first thing I noticed be honest
completely honest because your ick was
honesty
are they real
[Applause]
we said are they real
hey she said in that chair though
everybody at the crowd went
is that important
um I really like the eye contact for
sure there was intensity there which was
good made me question his misogynistic
mindset though with the last comment but
we can we'll see you asked
you oh you asked
you know what
that [ __ ] away I hear yo bro move it bro
bro
not only did you ask it's you came out
with your titties hanging out yo what
you mean yo bro
yo and then she got the girl to say
misogynist get the [ __ ] out of here get
the [ __ ] out of here get the [ __ ] out of
here it's already won so whatever like
he chooses I win
because I think I'm great so
I got your head are you going good how
are you good good to see you back here
thank you I'm glad to be here do you
remember my name is not Grace by the way
you're dumb are you strolling that's not
a thing that's what I'm saying he said
it's Divina she went you're already dumb
this guy's great yo these girls are so
stuck up it's crazy this guy is great
these girls are so stuck up it's crazy
focus on the positive this guy is great
let's get to this you're dumb you're
stupid
um no it's not
[Music]
a fast letter there are a lot of names
you literally had two girls come to the
family you only had to remember two
names no I did it awful job didn't know
yeah you did my name is rafara don't
forget it I'm not gonna say it twice
yeah yeah okay
[Music]
I'm being alone if that's what you want
to ask have you ever been with a black
woman before I have you have why is that
a red flag
it's kind of giving jungle fever
we're bringing it back oh my God
they're the same people with the
different shape oh my God let me ask you
a question if you answer it's your fault
oh my babe bring it back bring this [ __ ]
back oh my God
oh
Emily all right so we're going to ask
you to eliminate one I eliminate myself
and get the [ __ ] out yo
you asked him he's ever been with a
black woman he said yes and you're like
that's a red flag
what's the first thing you know
have you ever been with a black woman
yes that's a red flag what's the first
thing you notice uh honesty's a big
thing uh are they real misogynistic
didn't say people it's the same people
this may be the dumbest cast I have ever
seen on one of these dating shows easily
oh yeah easily one of the that I I can't
think no of a more dislikable cast and
you're gonna come at somebody because
they've dated a black girl before jungle
fever yeah that's cause you a black
woman
because you dated black women before
what do you mean what I'm gonna do with
that like why like why like what was the
reason what did you see in me that made
you want to choose me you could [ __ ]
sing yeah and and you know it was pretty
[ __ ] good yeah
um I hate when I hear that [ __ ] and uh
some of you women do that a lot right
why did you choose me like what made you
say you're here
okay okay you're here
all right uh you're here
but why tell me why like can you write
and you're here you're [ __ ] here
you're here you you are here can we
enjoy that can we appreciate it
she's mad at him talking about jungle
fever and this is why am I here is like
I thought you sang really well
a skill that she has is what he said he
appreciated no no that's not good enough
give me more yeah so he's appreciating
you for what you can do yeah not what
you look like necessarily your skin
color yeah and you not please bruh saw
her ass in the trash along with the
other girl
um
I don't know I like your smile
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop we're good we're good we're good
we're good we're good we're good we're
good we're good we're good we're good
we're good could it we're good we're
good we're good we're good wrap it up we
are good wow wrap that [ __ ] up
okay you know what though listen you
know what I try to um I swear to God I
try to do sometimes I try to get outside
of myself to do nah bro
bro listen right now I respect women so
much so let me just get out of myself
okay oh my God I want you guys in the
audience ladies especially to tell me
okay
ladies tell me
is it just you know he's not some of the
most dislikable people you've ever seen
on these dating shows or am I just
coming at this from the man perspective
I'm being on fire maybe I am maybe I'm
missing it
maybe I'm missing it
no man no that's your problem
yeah
listen tell us what you think huh tell
us what you think uh what what did you
who was the most dislikable person
and yeah
um I would have eliminate my I don't
even want to know who he choose not this
point
I don't care
I really hope he eliminates himself
yeah we'll probably both agree on that
oh I just
sometimes I watch some of these videos
and I'm like bro are they just casting
really hateable women or is there
something wrong with me
and then sometimes I watch you know like
I don't think it's me bro these women on
these videos are just really dislikable
I was like God damn
the entitlement is crazy but hey maybe
y'all feel differently
Italian